hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica below
zero now i
am not gonna be as big of a [ __ ] baby
as i was in the last one but what i am
going to do
is i am going to go find some way to
start
building stuff now i know that the store
is going to unfold and all that stuff
and people are going to talk to me and i
sent out my stool sample up to the space
station and whatever but i need to
figure out how to get
the builder tool because without that
i'm not actually going to be able to do
any base building
which is like a big part of this game
and if there's no base building
then that just seems weird and i don't
believe in that at all
but since i don't believe that i'm
actually not gonna let that get me down
and i'm just gonna go out and about and
see what happens
is this dead no that's good okay so
let's go out
it's beautiful as always it's
freaking gorgeous and that's nice and
all
but at the same time i don't like it
also i updated some stuff in my
recording
uh equipment finally i am the kind of
person that doesn't update
unless i have to uh but i finally
updated
and uh things should run a lot smoother
than they have in the past
oh that is buttery smooth i'm not
getting a single stutter anymore
oh this is a dream oh hey hey dude hey
dude
hey dude how you doing hey how you doing
okay so i don't know exactly where i'm
going wait a little fast so i don't know
exactly where i'm going
but i'm just kind of getting a lay of
land because i know
i'm kind of near well no i'm not where
am i
wait where am i whoa whoa what was that
i saw something under there
what was that is that just not supposed
to be there
i think that might be a bug or something
oh well whoa hey
hey dudes what are you doing out here
oh that looks unfinished i think i'm
reaching the relative
outskirts of where the game is and is
not finished
hey dudes can i steal your air which is
a weird thing that i can do to you guys
i don't know how i sucked that out of
you but i don't think either of us are
happy about it
sploosh whoa why are you being cute
i have the ceo on the line goodall this
biosample you sent us it bears no
resemblance to your biometrics
i think in the alien facility it spoke
your name
what is happening down there goodall i
would ask your colleague only he
disappeared
i silence where is the other one if you
mean to make vice president manage your
people
yes sir what is this
sir if i could just he's gone sam i'm
sorry
i've been stuck in middle management
since i graduated
i know i'll try harder i have to go
okay well that guy i love that character
whoever is the voice actor for that guy
perfect
no better the dialogue didn't match at
all i don't care that was awesome well
done
we are completely lost i have no idea
where i am hey can i get some o2
thank you hello can i have you yoink
now a lot of this game is going to be
unfinished but until i have
a more specific set of directions to
follow my best
hey oh you nibbled that right out from
under me
congratulations you scared me way to go
yeah so
in the meantime until i have a more
specific direction to go
robin you might be down there on your
own for a while i'm sending down a
builder a builder tool
that's exactly what i was looking for if
i had known that i would have stayed in
the safety of my own pod
i didn't know that you were gonna be
delivering it to me hand personally
sounding down like an airdrop should i
sure wish i could see with my eyes
that'd be nice um hello okay oh
hey that's on the i no wait no
no i was no don't you send it down
directly where i was but i'm not over
there
no no oh it's okay oh
there's an opening here oh well then oh
then convenient okay i did i had no
foreknowledge
of anything coming down here so the fact
that it dropped exactly where i was is
literally just a coincidence i swear to
you all right what did we get
yes
i can feel safe i can feel kind of safe
because i got a builder tool
and i'm pretty good and so with a
builder tool i'm able to build stuff
if you didn't know about builder tools
that's stuff you can build with okay
this is good
everything's looking up everything's
looking good i know there's nothing
scary down here
see once it just takes me a little time
i get comfortable
contractors
please study your individual briefings
failure to deliver on objectives will
result in payment deductions
and or your removal from the planet oh
safe
oh okay thank you i think all right so
if i am not stupid i would take
my [ __ ] from in here my titanium
my silver my
lube my silicone rubber uh
some copper uh quartz for glass
and not that much quartz and one more
titanium
and maybe get rid of the salt and i'll
take that with me maybe one less of that
maybe one more titanium and then i'll
cook up this arctic peeper
and eat it and then i'll be good to go
right
that sounds good can i mention for a
second like
this is so cool like as much as it
terrifies me
it also is very captivating like the
ocean
this isn't even the real ocean but this
ocean in and of itself is so
in-depth so so broad and the work that
they've put into it already
it really does build on the subnautica
that was there before
like in the original like the the wonder
of it the open
spaces of it the the alien nature of
everything in this place the way it just
doesn't make any sense at all
and yet it's all there and it's crazy
when you really think about it and it's
so cool that they've managed to
deliver this experience again and it's
not done it's going to be
years before it's done probably another
two years of
slow updates but it'll get done and
they'll do it and
that's like a fascinating that's a
fascinating thing to see
and i'm i'm just like i'm really blown
away by the level of a detail or the
attention to detail that they put into
these games
i just whoa i think it's cool hello
whale i don't even need to make a home
oh [ __ ] all right how about that
whoa okay can i get in here no
can i get in here at all no is there an
entrance
i thought that was an entrance over
there but apparently not let me see if i
can build one um
hatch here we go no oh
is this like placeholder [ __ ] and it
doesn't actually work
uh i think this one yeah this oh
oh it's a dead oh what's that can i have
that
can i has that hello 30 seconds
oh that's a problem okay but i see uh
okay wow i'm gonna die
okay i better hurry can i just get out
whoa straight through the window then
all right well this is bizarre why is
this down here in the middle of nowhere
you think that we would have known about
this or someone would have had said
something about this
i mean it's not like it's the same
situation as before
i guess i should understand that this
has now been thoroughly explored
how what kind of vessel i have not
granted you permissions for that
information
i can't help you if you don't tell me
which data format
do you accept words mostly
i have added the information to your
databank
oh listen i need something to call you
we do not use words that way i used to
have a pet bar wall
i called him ketchup don't make me name
you too
you may append my seed coat to the
species designation
you may call me al ann i waited my whole
life to meet a space-faring alien
you're telling me your name is alan is
it insufficient
no no alan
it's perfect let me see about that
vessel
oh nb thanks to you for playing early
access once story and gameplay from here
are very broken until later updates
well i wouldn't expect anything less so
let's just go explore as much as we can
and hope we don't die which is almost a
definite all right
but that doesn't distract me from
exactly what i wanted to do before
so that's not a good base to start from
i'm in a relatively
different area here we've kind of
reached the oh
we've reached a slightly different biome
here with
weird stuff
i'm just looking for a good place to
build my base
like good resource distribution good
access to what i need
not too far away from the things that
are going to kill me
or far enough away from the things are
going to kill me not too close
to the things that are going to kill me
and yada yada
where am i a lot of whole fish not sure
if that's a good thing but a lot of
whole fish
hello oh hello can i climb up here oh
hell yeah
oh is that a cave welcome to papa
oh come to daddy i hate hate myself come
to
me come to mark that's who i am
oh hello ah i'm not really sure about
subnautica having
land caves but uh
i guess the last game did too does this
lead anywhere is this nothing
oh
ah okay i'm sure that there's nothing up
here i just kind of want to see it
like a lot like a lot of what i was
saying before the game is going to be
very broken
very incomplete very not done but that
doesn't mean that there's not cool stuff
to see
no poopy looks like a whole lot of
nothing
okay i don't know where this is in
comparison to whoo
whoa whoa i thought it was like teeth or
bones or something
it's a whole lot of nothing ooh what is
that oh is that the thing that i found
before am i over there
oh i am aren't i oh i am
oh i've been here before oh god damn it
i thought it was someplace new
still haven't found a good place to
build my base oh but this is weird
where does this go whoa oh
whoa i don't like the sudden darkness
is it nighttime i really hope it's not
nighttime nighttime usually leads to bad
things bad things that want to kill me i
mean it's not like it's any more
dangerous in the night but it just feels
a lot more dangerous tonight
give me give me a suck give me the suck
oh yeah that's good suck all right give
me the suck
i don't like how dark it is i'm also
kind of low
on battery i mean i'm not on this one
but i don't have a
spare give me this suck uh where am i
where am i i don't like it uh where am i
ah where am i where is this going ah
dad give me the suck i don't know what
this is oh it just goes down
where am i going oh oh
oh god ugh creepy as hell whoa on my
radar there's something
like way below this what is that
you see what i'm seeing is that like the
underground tunnel that goes um
underground i don't want to go down
there but it's something to see anyway
i'm really far away from my base now i'm
probably deep in the unfinished
territory it doesn't seem to go down
anymore from this maybe down that way
not that i want to but i have no idea
where i am
i'm kind of kind of running low on
oxygen so i might as well
make my way back okay there's pangus
where there's pangus ah there we go
suck yeah no
where's the goddamn sky give me the suck
okay where am i in relation ugh okay
whoa whoa ominous glow
wow
you can't do that to me
this is not cool oh what the [ __ ]
did i just piss my pants is that what i
did it was a wet sploosh i heard
can only assume i pissed myself hmm some
lights there but i don't know if the
lights mean anything i think this is
like what are you doing
yeah yeah yeah whatever uh he's just
back up to the island
screw that no need for that is that the
drop for the builder tool
is that what that is i have no idea whoa
hey buddy
i don't think i can make anything like
geothermal energy so i think
i i'm not going to go near the vents as
nice as that would be but i i don't feel
the need to do that
what i am probably going to do is i'm
going to build right here
in the twisty caverny areas someplace
where i can be deep enough that i can um
get a head start if i need to explore
down deep i'm near vines
actually this is a good spot right here
let me build it just a little bit lower
yeah oh hey buddy oh oh there's an air
air bladder
all right there's a few dudes but i
think this actually might be a good
place all right let's do it foundation
well you need lead for a foundation oh
[ __ ]
whoa whoa whoa whoa
hey [ __ ] no all right fine then
i won't build there screw you i'm gonna
build here then
dick as good a place as base as any good
good space base place multiperson's room
let's really get it wang doodled out
there in the middle of nowhere just
completely ignore the fact that i made a
foundation in the first place
and wabuski okay how about
some of this hatch and we'll put that
actually going into the foundation
because that makes
total logical sense all right now we can
go in
and bada boom emergency power that's
right
offline oh yeah power i wonder if i can
scan the solar panels from the other
thing that i saw before
i could probably do that all right i
need to go back i need to see if i can
scan the fabricator or something like
that
because if i can scan the fabricator
then i don't know that'd probably be
pretty good
because i need to be able to put a
fabricator in this one because if i only
have a fabricator or if i only have a
fabricator back in here
then that's not going to do me any good
that's going to that's going to do me
exactly no good
so let's not do that and let's get a
fabricator
maybe yeah probably not ah
no no no
how do i get a fabricator plan how do i
get any plan there's like no blueprint
stuff there's no way to get blueprints
how to be able to do it oh [ __ ]
oh where do those come from hey i can
make a wall locker
that's nice all right well one step at a
time
we'll worry about that later let's see
if i can make at least a battery
so we can't make that but we still might
be able to make at least
the um yahoosie do what's it
the yubsy wubsy you know the
smuggle blammer okay i need to make some
glass too
just in case sure i'm glad that hatch
didn't need anything
okay i'm gonna go i'm gonna try to scan
the the thingamabobbers
because that would be nice there it is
okay
come on baby let me scan you let me scan
you
god damn it okay so how am i gonna power
my base
can i power my base there is entirely
the possibility that this is not ready
like to power it that that is just a
possibility that could be a thing
like there might be other there might be
other things like this base that are
kind of partially built
but without a means to power my base
maybe maybe building a base in the first
place is kind of like a pipe dream and
maybe
maybe they don't even want you to do
that right now well i'm not gonna go
and just give up i'm gonna find out what
okay where am i okay let me wrap around
the back of that island over there
might be something over there whoa
hello sheer drop into nothingness
boy do i not miss you jesus
oh my god ugh even on my radar it's just
dipped down into nothingness it curves
backwards in on itself
that's no good that's not good for
nobody please don't do that to me
i'm not seeing anything i'm towards the
back now
eh i'm not seeing anything there's a lot
of places to explore around here and i
haven't even tapped like
whoa oh ooh
yeah i keep expecting to see like a
wreck or something down here but there's
gonna be no wrecks
it definitely wouldn't be rex and alan's
gonna be no help to me at all
whoa what is that weird
ugh it does it again it just drops off
into nothingness
it just drops off into nothingness
it's just a drop of nothing oh
no what is that
what is that sound oh what is this
it's a biome i found another one
i can't get it it's impossible oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh no what is that
gel sack great is that edible eat it put
it in my gob
oh where am i whoa where am i look more
gel sacks get them in me
oh something full of gel is this like
heating gel do i rub this on my groin
okay it's helping with my water
stabilizing
oh hate this place hate this place bigly
oh bigly hate it hey it's
threshers hey those all my old friends
oh great oh man all right oh [ __ ]
oh what no i i'm not dead
no no no no no no no what are you what
are you doing oh no it's bugged
oh no it's bugged oh it's bugged
oh god no no ah
no no oh no oh no uh well
let me drop the dead one then is that
gonna help no
oh oh boy oh i'm dead i'm dead
i'm dead no i
am oh this the darkness has come to
claim me
i am duh no
what not until you said the research i
called you did anything happen like
what huh okay thanks sam that was really
helpful okay what i gotta do i think i
gotta reload because if i can't change
out my battery i'm not gonna be able to
go anywhere
and i know it's shameful just to save
after i died but i'm just
i'm hoping hoping that uh you know
there's gonna be something
something for me okay here we go all
right good we're good
okay we are good let me make another
battery because i don't want to be out
and then let's go back to that place
the hell place with horrible [ __ ] oh i
don't have enough for another battery
all right well let's
let's not make another battery i like
living on the edge
i don't actually need to live life let's
go back to the horrible place let's go
yeah it'll be nice it'll be cool
actually i'm going to make another
battery you know what screw and screw
not having another battery i'm gonna
i'm gonna definitely have another
battery like having a battery seems like
a great thing
to have and to hold so i'm i'm gonna do
that and
not doing that would be like the
stupidest thing i could possibly do
because then i'm gonna
i'm gonna find whatever the leviathan is
in this game and i'm not gonna be able
to run away from not that i'd be able to
run away from it anyway with my stupid
little dinky little
power glide thing whatever whatever
let's go let's go to our death let's go
come on everybody hop in let's go oh my
base
hey it's my base it is real black
why is it blackened and really creepy
it's really creepy
i don't know i guess that's cool yeah
sure all right i like the paint
it's nice i guess
oh oh oh
oh what is that oh i know that was part
of it but what is that
what am i looking at is that a lily pad
is that a big-ass lily pad
what the hell oh here's your big-ass
lily pad
oh that horrible horrible horrible hate
it no
horrible horrible is it night
huh oh why am i here at night
oh why night wine
forgive me forgive me oh it's a thresher
it's okay
what am i looking at whoa what am i
looking at oh
where am i oh where's the ground where's
the ground
where's the ground where's the ground it
looks like there should be ground here
but
there there ain't or emma is there oh
there's ground i didn't have my
flashlight on
okay all right we're good
let me actually get into the biome all
right mistakes
have been made what i'm brave
oh okay we're in the biome
okay let me grab some of this [ __ ] eat
this stuff this in my gorb
oh i don't like this quiet
i don't like quiet oh it's a series of
tunnels okay
good to know why
oh okay good to know
whoa i went way downer than i thought i
did okay
go please go now now is the time to go
is it night
it is night oh it is night all right
hey sis oh things are real bad down here
do you think you could send like
i don't know a robot companion to make
me feel
safe all right so there might be
something i don't know to explore in
this biome probably not
considering that a lot of things in here
are unfinished uh
oh man i whoa
oh no oh no
oh no oh
no okay i don't know where i
am and i don't know whoa why are you
that's just that's the emperor huh
emperor oh you're you're a bit hello
hi yeah that's the cm
that's the simp hey [ __ ] off
hey you are you one of the babies that i
released hey you're friendly right
hey whoa hey buddy hi how are you
hey you remember uh not me but you
remember
somebody hey what's this what is that
hey
[ __ ] all right it's fine you are
i've got the enzyme i'll send it to you
what
huh i didn't know i was supposed to do
that
okay i did it oh goodbye
you're one of the children that i
released
that's what you are in case you didn't
know you were
so definitely one of them i found one of
the babies
it's not a baby anymore i was a big
very big i am way farther out than i was
hoping i would be
all right just gonna scootaly
not gonna look down i am not gonna look
down
don't know why i needed to get this
thing but i'm gonna pop it in that
rocket and i'm gonna
send her up into space boy howdy that
was not fun
i am unhappy about everything that
happened over there
but i did it cause i'm brave and i got
an
enzyme i got some emperor poop and you
know
i'm gonna smear that all over myself and
protect myself from disease
not that i was at risk but i'm gonna do
it anyway
can i have my flashlight there we go why
can't i have my flashlight out when i
run that's dumb
oh hello hi ah you're so warm
so nice of them to warm me up when i'm
there okay let's blast off another ride
do i even have another rocket how am i
gonna what is that poop clouds
what is that i pissed myself again
i think ah
that was too scary for what happened
i pissed myself again okay so there is a
rocket here
i guess all right okay i'll put this
enzyme in here
somehow can i put this enzyme in here
how do i
how do i do that wasn't there a thing uh
rocket needs repair well good thing i
have one of these
all right and shabushki
wow all right pop this bad boy in and
slam ding dong this is totally
coo oh well uh oh
oh i got us to get both sides of it
that makes sense okay is there anything
else that
wow i think i just tried to repair my
own brain oh no
okay we're fine all right all right see
you waiting for cargo it's
but it's but i did
but i put it in there what but i
but uh you said and i did it i
you said where to go oh wait maybe i
need to put it in
there's two storages apparently maybe i
can put it in the other side
okay how about now how about now big boy
how about now
yeah yeah no all right well that's not
working
all right well there was no point to any
of that i'm happy i did
all of that for nothing that's great i'm
super stoked about that
okay so that's not working although i
don't know why i expected it to
i thought there was gonna be something
considering it told me to do that
but if it's not gonna do that that's
fine i'm not gonna complain about it
actually i am gonna complain about it
but
i'm not gonna complain about it too
loudly hey poop pool
ah nice and poopy hey these weren't
these weren't looking too good before
hey they they fixed these up
it was a tiny update they might have
changed something but these are yeah
yeah all right okay all right let's go
back in the water
almost missed i'm gonna go i see two
landmasses over here i'm gonna try to go
over to where those are
to see what's going on while it's still
day this looks like a big glacier
iceberg maybe can i get up here whoa
all right well cool but a whole lot of
nothing all right there's another one
over there
yeah let's go for it what's the worst
that could happen i get eaten alive
like that ever stopped me
oh [ __ ] god don't scare me like that
you suck yeah you weirdo okay so he's
doing his thing over there
i don't know how i missed that last time
because it seems like he's
real obvious it seems real obvious but
uh let's give me the benefit of the
doubt here okay up up come on
there we go oh well i probably shouldn't
be up here with lightning that doesn't
look natural
that probably is not supposed to be
there all right well little
little snack for me might be a little
frozen but hey whatever's good eats
oh what is that what are they whoa
what's a fish
what the [ __ ]
that's new oh
my god hey you lost
buddy what the [ __ ]
just gonna save okay wow
um all right i uh
okay all right okay i think i can get
back up on
right here just gonna oh there's too
many there's more than i thought
let me up they don't look vicious
but looks can be deceiving hello ho
ho hello hi hello
how are you you've got some tusks i see
oh my goodness you're so big
you're all so big are you the
replacement for the big
old floating turds hi
hey hi you look like a whale
are you are you a whale are you friendly
are you a friend
you're a whale
you're a whale glow whale
okay um all right they don't seem to be
hostile
which is very good oh
whoa freaky
that's so weird can i ride one of you
guys
oh hey let me let me get up on you
yeah go hey what
i can ride it
i was just choking i'm
riding the whale
no flipping way
go baby go
go baby go i don't know where you're
going but
wow hey you got something on your back
there don't don't don't spoil me come on
i need this let me have this this is so
cool
that's such a fun thing it
serves no function in the game i know
this this can't possibly serve a
function in the game
but it's so cool i can
ride the whale that's so cool
oh man terrifying but cool
wow whoa wee
breaching oh wow
oh i don't know what we're doing he's
trying to shake me off all right okay
all right i'll let you go
you majestic creature you
you majestic creature get me the hell
out of here
give me a hell on this ice that is so
cool
oh that's so cool there's so many
holy [ __ ] there's so many oh hey no
don't eat me
don't eat me oh there's so many i mean
they're kind of bugging out over here
just go oh yeah there's
a few bugs that's fine builds character
this is so cool there's so many
wow oh hello what are you oh any other
things besides whales oh please tell me
you're the plan or something
maybe to get like some power or
something nah i don't look like
anything's down here
uh looks like it will be in the future
but nothing right now
oh damn it okay thought i was gonna get
something apparently not
but that's all right ooh that drops off
but this is cool
that's really cool oh that's really cool
hey buddy whoa your mouth is big
you got big mouth hey whoa
oh my goodness it's just as scared of me
as i
am of it swallow me whole
oh god oh god
that's so cool this is the coolest thing
i've ever seen in my life
okay i love this game this game is so
cool all right
that's so cool that's awesome
that is awesome either way i'm gonna end
this episode riding a whale
cause that is just the best literally
the best i'm falling in love with the
ocean
it's so beautiful it's so nice and
at least this part is not deadly so
thank you everybody so much for watching
in the next episode i'm gonna keep
exploring hopefully not run into
anything terrible
and uh yeah maybe i'll actually build a
base and figure out a way to power it
but if it's not available yet
then we'll just have to wait till the
next updated game thank you everybody so
much for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
you